or Into Mister Bill O'Brien,
who worked on the Sydney Harbour Bridge as a carpenter during the building of the bridge German prefers getting a job,
Mister Brian oh yes, I dare the year judge are few and far between at that particular time
and I was very glad to hear a job there and unfortunately a worker on the bridge had fallen from one level to another,
not a great distance, but this had put him out of action and that I was offered the job,
which who is really good for me and bad for him
and I remember going into the office on media sell side of the bridge
and they accepted me having found that I had worked on are rather high buildings have rather high at that stage
and Sydney 's history and learn from their host told to and come in the next day go across the harbour
and don't go to the office underneath the bridge there
and present my credentials so are the next day I cut across on the ferry
and looking up at the bridge at the timber work that I could see up there.
These are timbers were going to support the ball out of concrete that it was over the arch where the trains are at this
stage because it's the motor cars that go through them
and that this was also noted to support they hear a top portion of the year pylon now is told.
I'd be working on the north side on the pylons
and burden across the arch where it was necessary to halfway home looking forward to this because certain I heard there
are paying pretty good money compared to am what other people are getting
and there were all these people out of work and I had had a lot of that.
How to work myself having suspended five-year bound apprenticeship and don't let apprenticeship to come out
and make a fortune in the world and find that to everything was disappearing in a way of jobs
and that having months in between gardens is very disappointing time and Seo
and Irish really delighted to be starting on this bridge I had it played many times to get a job on them that that was
almost impossible that many people who have had the same idea that I'd had and then here I was with John
and on my way across the harbour on the ferry and looking up at the structure
and the two miracle is from down the ferry that I could see up there that I would be working on those seem to be about
six by six inches square and about twenty feet may be fifteen feet high.
when I actually got up and down I found it was fifteen by fifteen inches and some other eighteen by eighteen inches
and twenty five to thirty feet nine as is quite a surprise,
as wondering how are going to move it around was then I found that the all the cutting was done on the road level
and that these were taken up by crane into their position had meant you only cut them once because Sir,
when the crane do the job of lifting up they had to be right and it meant that don't quite a bit of firm
and sort had to go into the job that you are doing now.
I started up their are on this construction of the supports that would hold the concrete of the arch on the pylons.
This is the archers there are called them out of all this and that there was semicircular barrel type falls.
This created the ceiling of those that portion through traffic now passes through due
and what sort of timber you use the type.
Yes, the timber was all our ego, which shows a wholesaler rather pleased with.
Because so it meant that do your tools would do and not be getting a very bad time.
Other members been a hard worker something of that sort out the tools which are all carpenters
and their own tools so they always interested in what you happen to the my job
and I will miss this is served pretty expensive thing when that when you are out of work.
I have been out of work and got a replay something are now after it
and all what I was on that particular section there.
I found I have to do something is a bit unusual to me are the timber to bore a hole through it
and some pieces were eighteen by eighteen sitting on another piece eighteen by eighteen,
which gave your three feet through and as you had boreholes through this the bolts they had big air driven drills
and these girls had a mighty big hose connected to them how you had to stand up there with your legs apart
and whole that drill in a hole that you had made in the timber with a thing called a white punch
and the sermon just simply chop to a piece of the timber out in round section seven of the end of the drill which did
not have a leading bet on it and it would sit in the whole,
then you had a hole that drill that is served three feet long drill at protruding out of BDO machine has so that was
perfectly levels straight it agree if you're on top of it.
The legs apart, you had a whole it so that that it was going to go through three feet of timber
and come out somewhere near the middle on the other side. Hopefully right in the middle.
I found this was quite quite a job to do because served your aware
or would stink if you didn't lifted out under clear it
and put it back in now if the debt stack that meant the drill went around and as Europe many high up in the air.
There is nowhere for you to GABA down so you're pretty careful about business
and as you herded labouring parents switch off the air and followed out
and make sure it was clear again because I did have an experience where the drill:
in a bit caught in the drill started again around because I let it go,
but there are other soon chastised about that way of doing things
and that ever after that I was very careful about that building a procedure is as Nobel don't let go story
and yet as a drive
and then they said them they were building a platform to go underneath the bridge on rails to be used for the painters
to when the term do the bridge from the under position and this would travel from one side of the bridge,
the other a rear permanent structure.
The painting gantry
and he has arisen painting gantry paths was made down the workshops on the shore where Luna Park was eventually
and they are sent down there to put the decking on the metalwork of this servant painting and well platform
or want whatever you wish to call it and them. This server. This was a great experience.
After several months out of work to suddenly come into replace the resolve hell let lives with drilling machines
multiple drilling machines are punching machines punching pieces out of the steel plate
and mighty big blast furnaces which were picked up by cranes which are up on the roof of the workshops
and that just taken from one end of the job.
The other rather than try
and turn the job around because it the hello roar of these things say it was an absolute nightmare
and having had a very quiet time of being out of work without any noise as this was certain something that third took a
lot of that taking IAM found that when I went overnight. I just couldn't sleep.
I'd hear all these things going on and that I'd wake up
and think I've got to get on with our guardian going him at a sleeping
and this went on to a couple of nights before I got that bit settle down to the conditions in those workshops,
but to sell those things happening there was an amazing engineering workshop.
I'd never seen multiple drills working boring about six seven holes of the one time in one big piece of black plate so
preserve every day was an amazing day for me
and I appreciated the workmen that we are using all this equipment are eventually we finish this certain platform
and to whom it was served to be taken out later
and attached underneath the bridge then I returned back up onto the top of the brands
and I found that at that stage of your salary with Sam dependent on the heights above ground level that you worked on
and that each day if you alter during working position you would get a different rate of pay now eventually because of
the office there was a was on about that.
She seems you had to calculate different rates of over people move around systems.
It is better yet that that's certain something I'm afraid that have a terrible time with that
and it meant that if you went up top firm for an hour and you had to go down to
and do something you step into your job and they had to alter this pay rate again.
So after a while I think that if out of the difficult they made at a flat rate,
but I know we were getting seven pounds fifteen, which hi, it is amazing at that time,
whereas soon the carpenters working down on the RAID level of the Department Iraq Main roads.
They were just getting over three pounds and three pounds fifteen elegant wires
and then where we really felt that that we come into a goldmine and working up there.
We didn't mind how high we went what it is, did you see anything unusual from working up.
I well we has to notice served the Blue Mountains every morning
and then on some Angolans with dampness coming down over portions of the rocks on the Blue Mountains you've said
listening as though it was a mirror Justin spots where there is a lot of the soakage apparently
and also the temperature down in the M ground level area.
It would perhaps be just normal and ordinary Day in Sydney but by the time we got up the top.
It could have a terrific wind up there be a very cow and a concern that nothing to protect your much they are,
you had to adjust the work out your own means of far staying there because is very little in the way of protection,
no safety belts or things that years today on projects that sort to do have a lucky escape still no
but I had some experiences where I ran. I had to claim down a set of stairs that day.
We just put into a platform where people had to work and cut off a piece of timber
and I had nowhere to put that piece of timber so having cut the piece of timber are found, but the saw under one arm
and a piece of timber with that but I just cut I'll climb back up using the other arm to hold on
and place it somewhere safe and then go down
and continue on with the job I was doing though one of the jobs that I found in a very exciting one was to
and put in a steer down a staircase down to a platform where fellows were going to work for a period of time
and the usually the rigours would do put in the platform and the carpenters would do have put the stairway down there.
This usually meant there are going to work on the platform but a long while if if they were not get any work.
Therefore any great time because they don't slimmer down the sides or walk up the rivets and that's how it was done.
We also put a lot of staircases right across product halfway.
We are working on the arch and inward the treads of the staircases were done in Word,
because certain they would don't have to be taken up again further different procedures of going on the bridge
eventually of course they would all be steel plate steps that that that stage we had to go up
and put the wooden ones in and that was so exciting, and because everything that day was that you can't more discarded.
You had to make some provisions for getting it away to a safe position, you couldn't just flowed over because,
as people working down below and also the other fairies and other boats going through on the harbour.
So when I say that turn hanging on was the main thing.
Another thing, of course, Liam to stop the rust problem all the steel had been known
and coated with some material to run.
The rust problem now this meant that it was Sir slip bread and then there were times when you get on your boots
and there on your tools
and things you be trying to drive a nail new find that you had paid on the end of a hammer wet paint pan
and you don't lose your your aim was aim of the right begin slip off that nail pretty easily
and this work the balance than
when I say that the many exciting things that there nature that happened while you are there to remember any accidents
that happen to other people know fortunately I was soon not in place to anybody who ran had an accident in the period
that I was working on the bridge management of the working conditions generally.
ISBN working conditions, of course, receive our own flower you didn't get holidays you didn't get sick leave
and their I just come out of a five-year bound apprenticeship with another company and then to go up there
and get all the that money which is a terrific amount that the time I was that the happy to do so. That term.
I didn't worry much about holidays, sick leave. This sat only came in later years.
Whether improvements for people generally in the trade.
We remember the union that I was I was a member of the union from my apprenticeship days right as an apprentice right
through which union was that that was the building workers industrial union being a guest firm DMM
and union activity during the building of the bridge, PS2 around meetings if Tuam
and discuss matters that were worrying members who are working on the bit bridge to try
and improve their ran working conditions
and am their wages home also the amenities that turn a really ever say non-existent.
We are to act are come to work going to a big shed that was right down to ground level and in there you just changed
and they got your bag of tools and gross as I said before all the tools belong to the
and each tradesmen they resent up on it, so you had to make sure that they were locked up of the night
and safe so that you have them to the next day 's work now from that shared they had ladders running up to the RAID
level that from ground level to RAID level
and they were just very very wide ladders they'd be perhaps six feet wired with firm to piece of timber on the outside
in one piece right about the middle of it and there are many of these which side-by-side so
when it was time to start work everybody you get on their way out.
These are trades of these matters well with two or three people on it. It was served quite an easy thing to do.
but when You run it a whole lot of people may be twenty thirty all on the ladder.
It began to go in and out and in and out and it was so like a ship at sea Seo and
and also if you began to think I wonder the timber is going to how a new patch halfway up so it is not much bird ever
goes your Gogo fairway and in the other way, of course.
To get up on the bridge was a cage, it had a top and bottom and wire around it and you all got in that
and stood absolutely packed
and I is a non-smoker of tries are never forget some of those pipes that they had had many many years of a stack under
my nose. That's, that's an array of morale always remember he would did it.
If you want to go to the toilet when you are at the top are well now that this problem viewed then could come down
and edited take era possibly half an hour
and maybe three quarters of an hour before it you got right up shop again without be tolerated.
Well, it had to be because certain there wasn't much you could do about it and then I don't think
when encouraged many other ways of doing things as you're in full view of me
and that people travelling on the harbour and on the sure solidity do well.
The Internet be able to get in the left during working hours. They are because then that there would be a terrific